this is Startalk I had read about
something called modified Newtonian
dynamics that was introduced as being a
possible model that doesn't presume the
existence of dark matter does this have
any credibility or is this pseudoscience
sensationalism I'm reading on time
science section
oh by the way it was Time magazine that
that we are questioning oh yeah he says
this is pseudoscience because I read it
on I read it on time basically yes an
indictment of Time magazine is what we
had it's a backhander didn't so he's
referring to modified Newtonian dilate
and we call it in my field modified
Newtonian dynamics and we call it a
field Monde MA and Rinna mourned and
it's an attempt to not be a prisoner of
the mysterious extra gravity that we
call dark matter dark matter is what we
call dark matter really I think should
be called dark gravity because 85% of
all the gravity in the universe has no
known origin exactly so dark gravity
right why would you call that dark
matter you'll even know if it's matter
so we shut the hell up but we know it's
not gravity we know it's definitely
because and that's because we know that
the expansion is accelerating is that
normative or this dark energy that's
dark energy right right no but just stay
with the gravity at the moment okay so
so there's things keeping galaxies and
galaxy clusters together right there's
an extra force of gravity operating that
we cannot account for by anything that
we see and even anything that we don't
see that we know is made of real matter
like black holes or dark clouds or dark
asteroids week you can add all those up
we have a way to account for those right
and we are in some places a factor of
ten in other places a factor of 100 off
when accounting for this what's making
the gravity right okay so so there's a
group that that that explored the
possibility that maybe Newton's laws of
gravity need an extra term in it but we
know new norms of gravity work in
certain situations but the situations
where it fails maybe you have an extra
term there a term and an equation allows
it to calculate
other kinds of situations guys so they
just put in a term and said here's this
term will it work and surprisingly they
got explaining some things that had
otherwise been explained by dark matter
right and there's certain certain
galaxies that orbit one another in small
clusters and so it's an intriguing
alternative hypothesis and it's got it
had some legs but every now and then
somebody will discover a system that is
not explainable by by my mom it and that
sort of sends him back a few steps
throws a monkey wrench into the plan
throws a monkey wrench but then they
come come back the point is right now we
have no idea what dark matter is so you
cannot completely shut down that
operation right because it's trying to
come it's trying to explain things
without anything exotic such as what
dark matter would be and so I don't have
a problem with that exercise ease are
respectable scientists doing respectable
work with postdocs and graduate students
and things so but there are some cases
that it cannot explain that's yeah so
you can't say well throw the whole thing
out the window cuz nobody else can
explain either right right Who am I to
say get out the room when I will have a
better explanation okay so that's how
that this so so yes it's on the it's on
the the edge of science that's on the
edge but something it's not really
pseudoscience no but it's on its
frontier science thank you is frontier
science that has a lot of people who
doubt it right but not on a level where
we're gonna not gonna discount it we're
just gonna doubt it we're just gonna
doubt and you know what we call that
science science
you